okay yeah so is that offensive yes or no
and is it true yes or no
offensive yes true no it's not true I
don't think strippers are not hoarse I
don't think so okay yeah I don't think
so either but it's offensive it's a you
don't think it's true I don't think it's
true
I don't think it's true and I suppose it
can be offensive depends who's so
strippers are not hoarse I don't think
so no okay
I have nothing kiss all true and I think
it's only offensive if you're either a
horror stripper
is it not true
because to me a horror is someone that's
promiscuous right so to me what's more
promiscuous than taking off your clothes
for money then you could say any past
and that post is a bikini pick on
Instagram as a whole yeah I would say
that too but I mean my definition
is if you're having sex with multiple
people throughout a short period of time
consistently I would call you a hoe I
would put them in that category too only
100 they're at the top of the category
for me but if you decide to go in if you
want to be up and down a pole and make
money for it but you're not sleeping
with anyone to me that's not her because
you could sleep with two people in your
lifetime I'd be throwing it back for
money I don't think that makes you a hoe
do you think the majority of women that
are taking off their clothes for money
are super selective with who they sleep
with
um in general not not I know there's
exceptions but in general
probably not however there are there is
the exception but but as a general
statement it's kind of true I don't know
I still I still don't think he's true
personally I don't know no okay why am I
wrong
I just feel like calling strippers I
don't know it's like like she said I
feel like they could be quite selected
for who they're sleeping with they're
not necessarily hoes because just
because they're throwing a back for
money doesn't mean that they're out
there sleeping with multiple men and we
don't know their circumstances like we
don't know why they're stripper they
have their reasons if you're a robber
but you have your reasons for being a
robber it doesn't make you not a robber
okay you got me there
um
it still makes you a rubber because she
stole at the end of the day but
stripping is just it's different it's
like
is promiscuous yes or no no no you don't
think taking off your clothes for money
and putting your boobs in a stranger's
face is promiscuous I mean that's not
not at all I mean shaking ass and like a
stranger okay any man can pay fifty
dollars and your boobs are in there in
their face it's not a little okay it
depends I feel like it that's an
extensive stripping like there's some
that are fully undressed and then that's
the ones that you know cover a little
bit so I think I think there's a certain
level to it right well but we're talking
about in general not not there's except
you know there's the I'm sure there's a
virgin stripper out there yeah that's
that's what I'm saying so I don't think
they're necessarily hurts like they're
virgin strippers so I promise you said
something yeah but in general in general
would you say they're more promiscuous
yeah than the average girl sitting on my
couch would you say you're equally as
promiscuous as a stripper the thing is
you can't tell because this
is like
a triple like you you can't tell you
just can't tell like I could see someone
on the train fully clothed and in like
on underneath she could be sleeping with
like 50 men where as a stripper like
just because she's naked or like you
know okay so if one guy's a pickpocketer
right and there's another guy that robs
banks for a living right does that make
the make the first guy not a
pickpocketer
like just because there's someone that's
a worse robber than him like aren't they
still all robbers
you know just because one's worse you
know one's Robin Banks right he could be
Robin Banks
but he's just pickpocketing he's not
he's not putting a gun out I
don't know I honestly can't say I just
feel like calling strippers like more
promiscuous than others it's just a bit
much okay is it true it's not true it's
not true not even a little true
um I think that the word [__] comes
from back in the days when it's like
another word for prostitute so if a
woman's selling her body for money yeah
she's a [__] but these strippers
yeah I agree with you
um but these strippers are not having
sex they are 100 promiscuous like
there's no way you can get go from that
you know they're trying to promote sex
sexuality
I think our whole thing is cut I can't
lie worth fifty dollars
but realistically you could be on a
train with someone and they could have
taken wood that morning but their
dresses
no but I could if you could have someone
that's a stripper she's tripping to get
through night school if she's got 50
boobs Fair paid if having good boobs you
can profit off it that doesn't make you
promiscuous though what does promiscuous
mean
promiscuous I mean you don't know what
promiscuous means it's the taking off of
the clothes
like you know strippers I wouldn't say
it's only sex sexual yeah energy
attention feelings thoughts
I mean there's nothing wrong with it
they're they're holding their hands up
say yeah this is what I'm doing for
money they're not sleeping with guys
there's nothing wrong being promiscuous
we are sexual beings as humans so I'm
saying some people have different levels
so it's not a bad thing that shippers
are promiscuous that's what like
um thing that they're in what field
they're in sex would you since they're
not promiscuous would you be okay with
your boyfriends going to a strip club
every day but they're not promiscuous
don't worry yeah because I'd be going to
one too you'd be okay
no I honestly would not be okay why not
it's just they're like no
and I'm not saying they're nuns I'm just
saying they have their reasons it's like
the average like I mean it's the same as
the girl on the train no I just like
certain strippers have their reasons for
what they're doing like that could be
the only source of income or they could
have set in circumstances as to what
they're why they're doing so but
personally like I would not want my
boyfriend to go to a strip club I
but the reasons like it still doesn't
take away from the fact that they're
doing what they're doing because
remember a guy could be homeless right
he but he doesn't have the option to go
down to the strip club and get a job he
just has to go get a real job at Subway
the stripper could do that
she just chooses not to she wants easy
money
she might enjoy it yeah yeah that's a
horse like easy money for their bodies
I mean yeah 100 however they might it's
you can't say that no one likes Easy
Money everyone wants to make money in an
easy fashion if someone could say if
someone gave you an opportunity not
necessarily to be promiscuous but
another another opportunity that was
quite respectable and it was easy money
you would take it because everyone wants
to make money easily the fact that these
in these individuals decide do you know
what I'm gonna be naked because it's
easier fair play at it I mean I could I
could sell drugs for easy money you know
but it's like at what cost right and
everyone's got a moral framework and I
would say definitely when it comes to
their bodies Horrors care less about
selling them
so
is I don't I don't see it as selling
though necessarily I for me what are the
men paying for
for the visual of what I
was like is it water wet like guys you
guys know I'm right
she she's she's based a little bit yeah
no I actually know it is because
obviously we're not disputing why
they're doing it you know people
sacrifice whatever it is what it is
because I'm saying they're selling their
bodies you know for money for sexual
these guys are getting sexual pleasure
out of it they're not like dancing to
make these men think about oh yeah I'm
gonna go to the bank do this my job like
it's a thrill it's an excitement I mean
it is what it is there is nothing wrong
with it sex is like the biggest industry
I think after is it before or after it
one of them hmm
it's really after I T is bigger than the
second one I'm surprised it's not sex
first yeah it's one of them what it's
between those two Auntie what do you
think um are strippers [__]
yes or no I'm still with the fifth was
it five fifties on the boobs yeah like
you just they pay 50 I don't know what
they cost you know when you said that I
mean let me know in the chat guys how
much did you pay for your last lap dance
I don't know the real cost I was just
totally quit can I just say something
totally up subject
once you said that you've got fantastic
pair of boobs thank you
are wearing a decent bra you have to
there's no spillage I love I love that
when you said 50 dollars what I saw was
her boobs I just took up my glasses and
my eyes still were going there I
couldn't help it because she's got
fantastic yeah I love that so yeah must
be nice um
but I personally think that um they are
selling
they're setting sex no matter how but
I I know some that um
that go there with their man's blessing
because to them it's just a way of just
going and getting some money let us go
and take it off and do whatever some
people really get into it so some people
it's like clocking in clocking out
but it's still in the sex industry and
that's what's selling
so yeah so yeah they are horse
I think the ones that sleep with men are
[__] and the ones that don't yeah
they're selling sex I agree so you've
got strippers and you've got stripper
holes you don't think you don't think
it's a [__] if you're literally being
paid to take off your your bra and put
them in random men's face
to me that's
if you if you that's what I said there's
some of them are a [__] those ones are
horse but you've got some that just
don't come off the pond and don't come
off the stage yeah some some people do
that just because they some women find
it empowering
believe it or not
but it's all in the sex interesting it's
all set in sex so so there's sex sellers
so at the end of the day what's it
what's a sex seller guys what's a sex
seller or
um this okay so this tweet got so many
views okay I even got the attention of I
was so excited I got the attention of um
Logan Paul's friend I'm trying to find
the Tweet I've been tweeting so much
this week yeah but he dated Lana Rhodes
you know what I'm talking about
Mike something you know I'm talking
about blessing yeah Mike something and
he tweeted back at me calling me a [__]
back I was like oh how much did you
charge him
like discuss that on the podcast let's
do it so open invite to Mike um I don't
know your last name I just know you as
Logan Paul's friend
um anyways
speaking of Horrors famous [__]